hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey corridor crew put
out another video that I can only
presume is an awesome video love these
the they are like the best one of the
best channels man always trendy that's
right yes stuntmen react to Marvel bad
and great Hollywood stunts let's just
swing it distant subscribe a quarter can
swing into it because spider-man John
John yeah I'm so sick of talking about
tension watch that's you that's you this
is me Chris Evans is dope you hit the
ground
miles an hour like Panthers break it
down for us alright what's up guys this
is stuntmen react we are honored to be
joined by D de Silva today he's a
transformer he is Black Panthers he's
done double for Optimus Prime and when
Optimus doesn't want to get banged up
this is a very comfortable couch I'm
glad I got good company so oh so he is
going to give us some insight into some
of your favorite Hollywood fight scenes
today I'm so excited let's jump in yes
target is a mobile satellite launch
platform oh yeah this is opening look
you guys see me almost half asleep on
the right now man we were in there in
the dark and then just talking I'm not
doing [ __ ] that's a look at 10:00 we
have got to be on the real ship I think
it said you're chairman or a Russian
ship the captain we're gonna have
murders this personnel just straight-up
dead Oh plugging
[Music]
oh here the big guys beefy boy Leonard
and big Bubba
tight black t-shirt gang yeah get busy
falling into each other I am ha ha to
fight Chris Evans is dope cuz he'll come
in and he has a dance background he's
attacked us so he understands rhythm and
beats and fight choreography is every
little sir - dancing that it is - actual
fighting martial arts he can just show
up and be my occasional I hold that eat
that clay Cullen is that a wire yeah it
was a wire pull it was fun that's cool
shot and there's me sleeping on Bubba's
leg how many days of this tape this was
two weeks Wow whoop and then one week of
actual shooting and Tom Harper is the
stunt coordinator on this and he looks
out for everybody so to get cool things
like good thing called adjustments it's
like giving a tip it's like a gratuity
does it based on like how hard it hit
you take how hard I hit you take how
hard the stunt was how nice equipment is
so what kind of adjustment did you get
for falling asleep on the guys like oh
my god good 500 bucks I think man that
was awesome hey he's down there yeah I'm
always down here profit do you not know
that no you know what else you don't
know a sponsor that's right today's
sponsor privacy calm is cooler than a
Hollywood stunt I'm gonna tell you guys
all about him at the end of this video
and how you get five months free five
bucks could be way cool nothing I like -
I'll tell you that much there's gonna
give me five bucks there's sports
privacy
that's you that's you this is me
hello there's a white guy who's done its
Derek Mears doing it
were you on wires yes I was wires to get
to the walls have to jump straight out
and have to use my right hand to stop
myself from swinging around no yeah once
that happens I'm actually free-falling
for about 30 of that then the descender
is a contraption that they use in
rigging that will decelerate your speed
as you fall down so they're starting to
pull in their to have to look cool danos
break it'll slow me down just enough and
now let me land freely so his landing it
still has that weight it doesn't look
like the the Hong Kong Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon I land on my tippy toes
and I can do ballet afterwards yeah
there's a week to it so they still yeah
those [ __ ] Shane oh wow oh that's
right
[Music]
it flies it's called a it's like a it's
so cool it's it's something you've never
really done before express it this is
something you've never really done
before and as a coordinator you should
respect that and find a way to get what
you want without endangering the stunt
person like how they built me up to them
I've never been on a magic carpet before
you don't just start at a hundred miles
an hour yeah I wait 100 miles an hour
but once you get into it once you get
comfortable they've already had a
hundred miles this looks like a CG fest
but for months Wow really I was not I
think that they were gonna add me smash
through the pillar with with me on the
back and they're like no no you're gonna
be on the back of that a little bit off
the fender yeah and put the bar there
for me to hold on to I feel like the
number-one muscle that you work on is
your grip strength I got the strongest
grip man really I remember watching the
rehearsals I was like this is crazy I
got the try that's a real motorcycle
yeah this is wired of course they
started back like maybe ten feet let's
say yes when they're pulling the guy is
a really Sebastian Stan moving him and
they got another group of guys pulling
the bike up oh really oh so it's not
just swinging up and no is that
something actually wrangling the front
Thanks he's trying to flip it down as
much as he possibly can look he's barely
holding on you know how do you rip your
pants myself
oh man I'm notorious so I'll do the
crazy and supposed to squat motion
sometimes I look like a fool other times
I'm like pow
yep
[Music]
this was fun so what they had was us on
the car pulling the motorcycle from the
front and they had it on a swivel that
will make it look like he got slapped
out a little tech would make the
explosion happens and I jump through the
explosion pretty picture that's me
reaching full out and swiping across the
back of the wheel
Oh a drink it was such a badass a
[ __ ] real yeah so they're pulling it
with wires the door opening who runs out
what the crazy no something our flipping
is that Wow oh my god okay but he's
still running with the car flipping in
front of them which is so cool but
luckily he's in a safer distance what a
crazy scene I've never seen this movie
ya know that the scene isn't very well
done but I do feel like you can bring
something to the table that most people
haven't talked about so everybody always
talks about the CG and like I was
actually surprised to find out they
actually had people doing motion capture
for this cuz like they're so fluid right
I kind of wish they hadn't
and kept it a little bit more rounded
than real because you kind of lose the
weight of the fight and that's what I
felt was like the bigness with it yeah
so there's no stakes right inside like
you're not getting pain in the spine oh
the students are getting D materialises
getting interrupted so now we're
starting to see bits of them and it's
like okay but you don't really ever see
a fight in this aspect so there's no
bruising there's no there's no danger
until the last second which is very
abrupt like boom he should be like
mantle dismantled for ya you just got
you have that moment of day there we go
now we have this dad look at that
emotion this knife just made me rethink
my life choices in costume do you have
like a special costume made just for you
to fight in so that you don't like break
it yes well it breaks blue things like
will fall off like little detailed stuff
so they have to glue it they'll have a
team of guys that are there to like do
that kind of stuff for us when I was
Panther on Civil War we only had one
helmet for me so we were very careful on
that helmet I actually got
the face by sebastian stand one day I
heard him say oh yeah any punch
something he walks up he's like y'all so
sorry I'm so sorry I'm like dude it's
perfectly fine the mass was there it
broke all the impact we just tried to
make him feel good yeah part of my job
is to make sure the actor feel
comfortable right cuz you want him to
perform as best as they can
I want him to have that same energy that
he had when he actually did hit me but
it was a really professional attitude I
try I try me it's hot
these guys are cool because they're in a
cool nice studio all my fights were like
it 90 degrees oh gosh no did that outfit
I threw up a yeah the suit was
collecting sweat yeah
so it really it's so I gained weight I
was like oh this is a 25 pound suit now
we were foolish later realize I can have
any complex away oh cool never done one
of those it's a wiggly woo we call her
rig Charlie which with her wiggly woo
she stops me and flings me into the air
and I fly into the the walkway into the
plane there wasn't a walkway
that was CG the first time we were
rehearsing and we were rehearsing
without the suit and I was landing like
skillfully surprisingly on my feet I was
like all right cool we put on my my suit
which is now soaked in my sweat they're
like all right ready and
[Music]
I go who's they they drop me a little
bit farther than they were originally
had and I landed on concrete on my
Rachel
Howie me and be in the cool stance
yeah okay Rosie I did a stunt over this
couch just a little bit ago and Guinea
comb twin thoughts they were so
impressed they all went out to Train
well they're at it I think I just saw
these privacy on new rocks or actually
the sponsorship for it which means that
you know go who's in the same kind of
feel on YouTube has the same category
let's hit them all sometimes you get two
different ad agencies hitting you same
as limits and expiration dates on your
cards it's real simple you do it all
online
they never charge you interest they
never charge your fees and they never
sell your data so you're good to go
well you got to do is go over to privacy
calm slash corridor crew and you'll get
five bucks just for signing up happy
they come
stop man stop man this was fun what's a
super fun thanks man you guys never want
to sit on the couch together like this
again and watch some stuffing I'm down
you can come over I gotta if you guys
would like to follow me ask some
questions I'd like that yeah you follow
them on Instagram it's me ex don't
follow the real axis silva and of course
if you enjoyed the show you know please
consider subscribing and please leave a
comment for any other cool fight scenes
I love fighting some really obscure
stuff please let us know in the comments
below it's a great way to know what's
out there thanks for watching everybody
yeah when I first started out here I
worked on that wanna hear videos it was
the Rayman oh really
and then actually pulled me on and like
maybe have a run in one film under my
belt and Here I am like seven years
later thank you dude so cool T I love
that guy he's so he's so badass but also
such like a geek yeah he's so fun to
watch and he's also really insights like
childlike
yeah he's the exact stuntman you would
want to hang him ya know and your
stomach I always expect that they're
gonna be like just run man and they do
those kind of guys do exist yeah a lot
of times I meets them and they do kind
of have this sort of energy and swag
about them that is a little bit more
like that are you telling me stunt
double for Black Panther I'm gonna
imagine a very different kind of human
being
I mean I mean that varies I'm imagining
you know like a white guy now I mean it
just by the fact of how he just there's
something about his energy that feels
like rather welcoming and calming and
it's just like he geeks out in the
laughter a lot which I is really this is
a really cool guy it just seems really
excited about the work he gets to do and
that's such a cool journey for him to
start out with corridor crew I just been
hired for something here it is
many years they're greatly exceeding
what he did did this video really shine
the light on for me is how often I will
sometimes just only assume something I'm
watching is CGI not factoring in at all
that they probably just had CGI
enhancements yeah to something that was
physically done in camera or practical
or whatever a lot of that chase I've
always thought that run moment was so
cool in a civil war as I'm like oh
they're really cars they're like what
are the car slowing down and so they
could run past them you know that
particular effect you know the fast the
supernaturally fast run you see in a lot
of stuff and that is arguably one of the
best times I've ever seen it done yeah
and so yeah I had no idea those magic
carpet things even existed like that's
totally new technology to me yeah sounds
super scary but also it really helps
that moment cuz I was sitting there
going this doesn't look like the CG I am
used to seeing and yeah in fact it's not
all CGI yeah well it was cool to see
some of the stunts that I've never
actually watching this I realize I've
never seen any of like making up or
behind the scenes for any of the MCU
films so to see behind the scenes
footage of one of the best moments in
all the MCU movies which was that whole
chasing and to see some stuff breaking
and broken-down I thought was really
neat with the motorcycle when Sebastian
Sam grabs the motorcycle I remember the
first time I saw in the theaters
everyone clapped for them yeah because
that was such a cool really well done
moment a punctuation moment yeah yeah
and to know how much work goes into
making this look as real as possible
with Sebastian Stan having to do it with
the stuntmen he's pulling off with the
wirework one that lit up that way good
to know how much of that was achieved in
camera blew my mind actually and it's
just for a few seconds spent days trying
to figure out something that'll be so
short lit the thing about filmmaking
that sometimes when we do reviews and if
especially if it's a movie I [ __ ] on so
watch your review back after it's
already up on YouTube but I'll be like I
feel kind of bad because it's easy to
watch a movie and forget just how
especially something that requires so
much action how much time goes into
something that only lasts a few minutes
for action scenes I mean yes and
can be applied for dialogue or whatever
you realize the layers in a video like
this because you go okay like there are
so many departments working for so much
time and to know that this one fight
scene was practiced and rehearsed for a
month before in the actual location and
then they went in and shot it you know
and it's just a few minutes of fight
yeah or even the elevator fight scene
and and Winter Soldier they said that it
took them a week to train and then a
week to shoot and it's it's really just
a few minutes and you think like oh it's
just in an elevator you know so he
really it's really working around a lot
of blocking but no that took a whole
week to shoot that one sequence oh it is
one extremely tight space which has got
an itching is harder exactly and with
yeah someone might think because you're
in an elevator and because you're it's
really more of a blocking thing you got
to work around that it might actually
take shorter to shoot but really it's
it's more complicated because you have
such limited space yeah yeah that's one
of the big eye-opening things that has
kind of floated my way in the past few
years is I've learned that there's yeah
always more CGI are often more CGI than
you would ever expect in places you
wouldn't expect it because you know I
don't always love watching behind the
scenes on like DVDs when they break down
special effects necessarily because then
I start to really see those but I always
appreciate it especially with stunts
because there is that thing where even
if I know how it works it's still
death-defying yes still tangibly well I
did not know that whoever was Sun Devil
for Chris Evans for Captain America and
when the car was flipping that there was
a real guy running with a car behind it
I always thought they just superimpose
and I'm like there's no way they would
have a real guy just run by the front of
a car really really appreciate that
because it makes those moments so much
more impressive because then you watch a
video like this and go wow you know that
yeah I really did in some ways happen
and then you can also appreciate when
the CGI is used more appropriately yeah
it's weird how CG enhanced just I'm just
talking about enhancements somehow that
can pull you out of something and make
you think that it's only that with the
black panther fight for example at the
end that fight does get a lot of flack
for being so it's just a big CG fest at
the end when they're sure this is like
oh wait they had mocap yeah those are
real dudes fighting you there
I was under the impression - that most
of that was just a computer yeah it's
all completely Admiralty g'd over what
the actual things that the actors and
stuntmen were doing which is a which is
a good way to have achieved that that
scene better arguably maybe then full-on
animating but I will say it is
absolutely true what he brought up is
costumes like that I don't know exactly
what the material is but they do soak up
your sweat and they get real heavy like
I haven't done a lot of stunt stuff but
I have done creature performance stuff
and so you'll be in a costume that's
like 40 pounds worth of silicone already
and then you're sweating into it silicon
you can kind of sweat through it with
foam a lot of things that are foam just
collect your sweat and get heavier and
you put it on and it's freezing and then
you come out and it's like warm and wet
you get very intimate with your body
there's some hard to film and stuff I've
never had to do like full-on like
character thing like that I was away
from last weekend because I was I was in
a short film you know he was talking
about he we were out in the desert
there's no a/c tents just broke so we
had no a/c to work off of and it reached
a hundred fifteen degrees of like 110
115 was the peak but that was every day
and we were out there starting at 7:00
in the morning and didn't leave till
evening
so it was blazing hot and everyone like
struggled for shade and to keep cool
there were scenes in like in these tents
they had to build and my character had
to wear these jeans these boots a tank
top a button-down and enough and a
pretty like heavy jacket that of course
got filled would sweat and on top of
that - I had to have a lot of blood on
me so the whole thing just got flooded
yeah yeah oh god I was like chafing my
nipples literally I was like do you guys
have had to ask the makeup guy like do
you have something for me because this
is scraping my yeah but you got to be a
team player you know everyone's on board
and I think for an actor it works in a
scene especially if you're dealing with
a scene in the desert so it's fine but
it's crazy to know that on these like
huge 200 million dollar-plus films a
stuntman when the black panther suit has
to have like a like even on the film
like that they're gonna have a struggle
well you heat conditions they're adding
on more I didn't even read a lot I
ever factored into me if like the sweat
adds on that much weight to your costume
I never thought about oh yeah one
sometimes I mean I'm working haunted
houses at least not the same but similar
like there was one we had that was in a
soundstage you start when it's light out
and you've got these guys in these tight
again costumes and sometimes not only do
you have the sweat and the heat building
up you know it's similar circumstances
it's physical but you're not you know on
camera or whatever but sometimes it's to
the point where people would have to be
cut out of the suits because they just
get too tight and they start to yeah
absorb too much and they're not built
for certain types of articulations so
there are so many considerations and Y
on a film set with all this budget all
these moving parts a really impressive
the amount of you know carnage that
doesn't happen you know when all these
variables working against this video
alone is giving me a much bigger
appreciation just for Marvel action in
general I know it's only covered a few
films primarily what you know he's
worked in at the same time though I feel
like Marvel action when Winter Soldier
came out it was really heavily credited
for how in-camera the action scenes were
people really wow there's actually great
choreography in here this is awesome to
see this in a Marvel movie then they
jump to something like black panther it
made me go these action scenes are not
just CGI fesses like some people just
chalk them up to that and you know guys
know me I'm a huge Marvel fan endgames
my favorite movie of the year it's a big
reason why they make movies there's no
effective is is because they recognize
the value in putting those big
impressive dongs on screen because
they're already bringing something
fantastical to life and I think it
behooves comic book movies especially to
put as much in camera as you can and
then CG enhance it and then get
criticized for being the CFS
[Laughter]
alright guys well this is great guys if
you haven't subscribed a corridor crew
easily like one of my top 5 favorite
YouTube channels currently they're fun
but they're enlightening I teach you
stuff about movies and performing I
really hope that maybe a series like
this could help lead to better respect
for stunts across the industry a visual
effects effect because this is one of my
favorite pros react series that I've
seen absolutely absolutely alright guys
well you can subscribe with the real
rejects you can click on notification
bell again notify would never got a
YouTube video up I want to end this
video or the patient the day shot to a
woman named Anissa Olivia Anissa
apparently last month you were pledged
to our page for a shout out and we never
gave you one and you send me a message
saying you didn't get one and I realized
we we didn't think it'd thinkers came in
a little bit later on the mother I'm
sure sorry we missed it usually John
supposed to notify aim the page and
update it when your pledge kind of no I
check the thing every day well I must
have screwed up it looks like your crush
Nick Daman you know we're sorry and is
you know how much we love and adore you
might yeah you're one of our favorite
people love chatting with you all the
time you had some things that you've
been wanting to send over to us for
quite some time you just found a place
in Our Heroes way Obama I have minutes
yes so we will be Ogrin of a P o box and
I will message you right away so you
didn't send us more [ __ ] thank you for
being so loving yes Lord a patient
especially a patient and generous and
say hi to your boyfriend for us so how
do you mother for me and your mother and
and no one else no one else just that's
the luck in life I love you my dear